well Forrest Gump just kept going and
going for quote no particular reason but
now we have a real life Forrest Gump I
hope he's not offended by that
characterization because he has an
actual honorable reason that he walked
Coast to Coast his name is Tommy
Pasquale and he just went from the
Atlantic to the Pacific 3000 miles it
took him 143 days and he said along the
way he quote listened to country music
Bruce Springsteen Classics and the will
Kane podcast he did it to raise money
and awareness for the many homeless
veterans in this country Tommy Pasquale
joins us now to tell us about it so I
think the entire country is wondering
about your entertainment choices out
there in the middle of the country no
one but
Bruce Springsteen and will Kane right I
knew you'd like that yeah only the
classics that's American icons if you
will right uh Tommy tell us first of all
your inspiration to walk from the
Atlantic to the Pacific yeah so it was a
goal of mine for the past few years to
do something special like this and uh
with that I knew that I wanted to pair
it with a really worthy charity so I
teamed up with the National Coalition
for homeless veterans trying to get
these brave men and women who have
served our country so valiantly off the
streets it just doesn't sit right with
me that on any given night 38 000
veterans go to sleep homeless in this
country and you raised almost a hundred
thousand dollars so far many people
watching right now can help contribute
I'm sure correct how could they do that
yes so you can do it two ways one you go
directly to the National Coalition for
homeless veterans website donate
directly there and check out all the
great work that they're doing or you
could go straight to my Instagram Tommy
underscore walks underscore America and
in my bio I have a link to a GoFundMe
where you can donate there as well what
a cause what a purpose different than
Forest Gump to actually help America's
homeless veterans now let's talk about
the walk 143 days
um I I want to ask you I guess the most
open-ended question I can but what was
it like
it was tough it's definitely the
toughest thing I've ever done uh but I
would say overall it was a great
experience I'm really happy I did it and
I can honestly say with a straight face
I'm very happy it's over as well what
was the scariest moment there was a lot
of scary moments just you know living in
a tent uh with the elements out there
you know hearing some coyotes in the
distance and just the wind whipping
against the tent I thought you know
there was times where I thought I'd
never see home again but it made it
through how's the body how did you feel
after walking for 3 000 miles in 143
days you know it was it was painful but
you know like I always say to everyone
who asked you know I was hurting the
whole way but I wasn't injured and as
long as I'm hurting and not injured I
could still play through it uh Tommy and
I feel like we know each other because
he's listened to the will Kane podcast
and I've said on numerous occasions I
want to do something like what you've
done here I've wanted to canoe the Lewis
and Clark path through the Missouri
River or ride a cattle trail from Texas
to Montana but what you've just done I
think is a bucket list check item for
many many people out there in America to
walk this country and you did it for a
purpose to help other Americans and I
know that I for one I think most of
America appreciates that about you Tom
Pasquale he's going to be on the will
Kane podcast this coming we're going to
go a little more into depth about what
those nights what those days were like
but we're proud of you and we really
appreciate you being with us tonight
thank you so much for having me on will
all right subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight